depuis quelques temps j'avais envie de
faire une vidéo sur le bitcoin et puis
il ya quelques semaines gilles qui est
créateur de la chaîne dorée car on a
fait une qui est vachement bien et l
affection je me suis dit qu'il restait
quand même quelques détails techniques a
expliqué notamment sur le concept de
blocs chain qui est la technologie qu'il
ya derrière le bitcoin est du coup j'ai
quand même décidé de faire une vidéo et
puis j'ai demandé à gilles de venir
m'aider un peu ça lui gilles tu nous dis
un mot sur la chaîne et le david et
merci de m'avoir invité à participer à
cette vidéo de nos avoir hérité à huy
parents de nous avoir invités donc y
aurait cassé une chaîne de vulgarisation
qui s'intéresse principalement à la
finance et à l'économie on y aborde des
sujets divers du genre qu'est les liens
entre l'économie réelle et la finance
quel est l'intérêt des différentes
monnaies ou encore qu'est ce que c'est
que le quantitative easing
bah pourquoi tu choisis les sujets les
plus chiants on parle aussi du loup de
wall street the big short on vous dit
tout sur les traders il nous explique
d'où vient l'argent
alors avant de regarder la suite allez
vous abonner america
on entend souvent que le bitcoin serait
une monnaie électronique
mais en fait vous savez la monnaie
actuelle elle est déjà largement
électronique 1 quand vous payez des
petites sommes vous payez peut-être avec
des pièces ou avec des billets mais dès
que vous faites une transaction avec une
carte bleue ou un virement ben la bande
des beats votre compte
elles créditent celui jeand'heur n'y a
pas d' échange d'argent physique un tout
se passe dans les comptes de la banque
donc une bonne partie de la monnaie
qu'on utilise et déjà électronique
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près quel
pourcentage il aujourd'hui la masse
monétaire totale en zone euro ces 11
milliards
et pourtant il n'ya qu'un peu plus de
1000 milliards d'euros en pièces et en
billets donc l'argent que nous utilisons
aujourd'hui est à plus de 90%
électronique
toute cette monnaie elle n'existe que
dans les livres de comptes de la banque
évidemment aujourd'hui c'est pas un vrai
livre c'est plutôt une base de données
de toutes les transactions
c'est à dire un gros fichier
informatique mais du coup si quelqu'un
pirate le fichier informatique ou bien
les faces le bitcoin c'est aussi une
monnaie électronique mais elle est
décentralisée c'est ça le mot important
c'est à dire que la base de données de
toutes les transactions elle n'est pas
gérée par une instance centrale comme
une banque mais elle est partagée dans
un immense réseau peer-to-peer c'est à
dire que tous les gens connectés au
réseau bitcoin peuvent héberger une
copie de la base de données qui contient
toutes les transactions une base de
données qui est distribuée comme ça donc
déjà on peut penser qu'elle est plus
difficile à détruire puisqu'il existe
plein de copies partout et puis on n'a
plus besoin d'une autorité centrale
comme une banque c'est à dire que
n'importe qui peut inscrire une
transaction dans la base de données par
exemple imaginons que je veuille acheter
sa lampe agile c'est là bas je page du
l'a acheté pour environ 100 euros donc
ça doit faire 0,20 pop up tu fais des
vidéos sur les traders et tu sais même
pas négocier david on peut te vendre la
lampe pour 10 bitcoin hockey divine
coyne combat pour payer la lampe
j'inscris dans la base de données
partagée le message mois david dunn dit
bitcoin agile la transaction est
enregistrée et les noeuds du réseau
comme unique pour se passer l'info est
ensuite gilles peut m'envoyer sa lampe
bon évidemment il ya un problème avec ce
système
aujourd'hui une banque elle sert quand
même à quelque chose et notamment l
authentifie les auteurs des transactions
avec ce que je viens de vous décrire on
a l'impression que n'importe qui peut
inscrire des transactions en mono quoi
cette recherche bitcoin t'inquiète on va
s'arranger mois david
10 bitcoin à gilles et alors et puis
autre chose à laquelle la banque sert
aujourd'hui tout simplement à vérifier
que j'ai l'argent pour payer
et puis accessoirement elle empêche que
n'importe qui viennent modifier ou
pirater la base de données des
transactions pour résoudre tous ces
problèmes le bitcoin se base sur deux
technologies
la signature électronique et la bloque
chain
commençons par le premier problème quand
on voit un message dans la base de
données qui annonce un transfert de
bitcoin comment on peut être certain de
son auteur eh bien on va utiliser le
principe de la cryptographie asymétrique
j'en avais un petit peu parlé dans mon
épisode sur les codes secrets en
cryptographie généralement on utilise
une clé qui permet de chiffrer et
déchiffrer des messages dans les
techniques de chiffrage des plus simples
on peut déchiffrer un message que si on
possède la clé qui a servi à le chiffrer
mais il existe des systèmes de chiffrage
plus sophistiqués comme ce qu'on appelle
lé algorithme rsa qui sont asymétrique
c'est-à-dire la clé qui sert à chiffrer
le message n'est pas la même que celle
qui sert à déchiffrer
par exemple si on possède que la clé de
chiffrement on peut chiffrer des
messages mais pas les déchiffrer il faut
une autre clé pour ça alors je suis
perçu en avoir bien compris comment
est-ce qu'on peut réussir à déchiffrer
un message mais ne pas être capable de
le chiffrer
suffit de faire la même opération dans
le sens inverse non non parce qu'en fait
le chiffrage asymétrique ce n'est pas
une opération lettre à lettre
elle transforme le message dans son
ensemble et elle est un peu lourde
compliqué mathématiquement est
impossible à faire dans l'autre sens si
on n'a pas la clé de déchiffrage
c'est un peu comme si tu avais un
dictionnaire français en droit mais pas
la partie en droit français
du coup tu peux facilement traduire un
mot du français vers le hongrois mais
c'est pas facile de connaître le sens en
français d'un mot en gros une d
utilisation classique de la
cryptographie asymétrique c'est d'avoir
une clé de chiffrement qui est public
c'est à dire que vous la donner à tout
le monde et n'importe qui peut vous
envoyer des messages codés mais la clé
de déchiffrement elle reste privée vous
la gardez uniquement pour vous vous êtes
le seul à pouvoir lire les messages et
ceux qui les écrivent ne peuvent pas se
lire entre eux en fait ils peuvent même
pas se relire pourquoi ce qu'on
utiliserait pas un chiffrage classique
avec une seule clé mais en donnant une
clé différente à chaque personne
le résultat sera le même nom et du coup
je vois pas vraiment l'intérêt ton truc
asymétrique compliqué
l'intérêt c'est que par exemple un
journaliste ou une agence de
renseignement peut avoir une clé
publique qui permet à n'importe qui de
leur envoyer des messages codés et il
n'y a pas eu besoin d'avoir un échange
en clair avant donc ça permet de
recevoir des infos tout en protégeant la
source
bon enfin c'est surtout très utilisé
dans les communications sur internet
ça c'était le principe de la
cryptographie asymétriques pour recevoir
des messages
maintenant le principe de la signature
électronique en fait c'est exactement
l'inversé de ça imaginez que j'ai une
clé de chiffrement que je garde pour moi
qu'ils soient privés et que la clé de
déchiffrement soit publique
si j'inscris un message comme moi david
andy bitcoin agile et que je chiffres
avec ma clé privée
ça donne du charabia
j'inscris ce charabia sur la base de
données est ensuite n'importe qui peut
appliquer ma clé publique et des
chiffres et de charabia pour
reconstituer le texte de la transaction
mais du coup on est bien certain que
c'est moi qui inscrit la transaction
puisque personne d'autre n'aurait pu la
chiffrer de cette manière là et donc
c'est ça qui fournit l'authentification
les transactions sont donc impossible à
falsifier sans posséder la clé privée
mais elles sont aussi impossibles à
répudier c'est à dire une fois que vous
avez payez vous pouvez pas nié l'avoir
fait et donc en pratique pour échanger
des bitcoins il vous faut créer un
compte et vous recevez un identifiant
une clé privée que vous gardez pour vous
évidemment est une clé publique qui elle
sera connue de tous les noeuds du réseau
et la clé privée vous permet
d'authentifier vos transactions
par contre si vous la perdez cette clé
privée c'est mort d'ailleurs anecdote
amusante à ce sujet en 2009 alors que le
vide qu il ne valait presque rien et
qu'il était facile d'en récupérer
james owen citoyen britannique en a
obtenu la modique somme de 7500 quelques
mois plus tard après s'être désintéressé
de cette monnaie électronique alors
inconnu james a tout simplement lors
d'un petit ménage de printemps
jeter à la poubelle le disque contenant
la fameuse clé privée qui donnait accès
aux bitcoin une erreur qui fait très
très mal puisque 7500 bitcoin
aujourd'hui ça vaut entre 2 et 3
millions d'euros
un détail très important sur la
structure des transactions quand on
inscrit une transaction on inclut aussi
une référence vers les transactions
précédente qui nous ont fourni l'argent
qu'on choisit de dépenser je vais
prendre un exemple au lieu d'écrire
simplement moi david dunn du bitcoin
agile j'écris moi david dunn dimitri
agile en utilisant les 10 bits cogne que
j'ai reçu avant-hier de nota bene oui
parce qu'avant tiers avec nota bene on a
fait une partie de bras de fer et puis
bah c'est moi qui ai gagné assez comme
ça que tu dis gagné toi alors peut-être
cours médecins non non mais on avait
déjà remis ça j'avais quand même gagner
peut-être pas buzzé monsieur bon bref tu
ma fille lady bitcoin et moi j'ai
inscrits dans la base de données que ce
sont ces mêmes du bitcoin que je vais
utiliser pour acheter sa lampe agile
alors quand on fait des références comme
ça aux transactions passées et ça à deux
intérêts le premier c'est que pour
valider une transaction on n'a pas
besoin de connaître la position exacte
du solde du compte de quelqu'un il
suffit juste de vérifier que les
transactions auxquelles il fait
référence comme étant la source des
bitcoins elles n'ont pas déjà été
utilisé dans une transaction passée et
puis le deuxième intérêt c'est que ça
empêche peut faire du copier coller de
transaction donc en train de me dire que
depuis tout à l'heure que j'essaye de
copier coller la transaction des dix
vitrines pour en récupérer 20 et que ça
marche pas en fait c'est normal à un bug
de mon téléphone
et bien non parce qu'on verrait que ça
fait deux tentatives d'utilisation de
ces dix bitcoin que j'ai reçu de nota
bene finalement le bitcoin se comporte
un peu plus comme du cash électroniques
c'est-à-dire de l'argent liquide
électronique parce que comme avec des
pièces ou des billets il ya cette idée
que la double dépense est impossible on
peut pas dépenser deux fois les mêmes
bitcoin qu'on a reçues de quelqu'un et
si nota bene talent et fils et j'invite
kane alors que toi tu veux m'en donner
que 10 pour la langue et ben il existe
un système de remboursement qui permet
d'utiliser ces vins bitcoin pour te
donner 10 bitcoin à toi et puis pour me
redonner à moi même les 18 communes
restant ce montant qu'a priori là on a
un bon système
il est ouvert il est partagé et puis il
ya une technique d'authentification qui
empêche de faire n'importe quoi il ya
juste un petit problème il ya plein de
copie de la base de données elles
doivent communiquer entre elles et
comment elles font pour se synchroniser
ça peut poser des soucis notamment s'il
ya des conflits quand quelqu'un essaye
de faire une double dépense imaginons
que je proclame donner 10 mythes cohen
agile d'un côté du réseau en utilisant
les dix bitcoin reçu de nota bene et
puis exactement au même moment dans une
autre copie de la base de données à un
autre endroit du réseau je déclare
utiliser ces mêmes du bitcoin pour
acheter autre chose à quelqu'un d'autre
comment les copies de la base de données
elle se synchronise et puis laquelle des
deux transactions va vraiment compter
l'idée c'est que chaque noeud du réseau
enregistrent les nouvelles transactions
dont il a connaissance dans une liste de
transactions en attente
et puis évidemment il partage
d'informations et donc tous les noeuds
du réseau possède une liste de
transactions en attente qui peuvent être
très légèrement différentes les unes des
autres et chaque ne fait comme
s'accroître sa liste de transactions en
attente
et puis périodiquement environ toutes
les dix minutes il ya un déni de réseau
dont on prend les transactions en
attente et on les déclare validé et tout
le monde se synchronise dessus ce groupe
de transactions on l'appelle un bloc et
on remet ça toutes les dix minutes
et du coup la liste des transactions qui
sont validées elles se présentent sous
la forme d'une suite de blocs 1 toutes
les 10 minutes et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça la chaîne de blocs ou bloc
chain mais alors comment est ce qu'on
choisit il ne qui détient les
transactions à l'idée c'est toujours le
même ou alors non on en choisit un waza
la règle c'est que pour proposer sa
propre liste de transactions en attente
comme étant le nouveau blog sur lequel
tout le monde doit s'aligner il faut
d'abord lui trouver un nom un
identifiant et on s'est mis des règles
qui font que trouver un identifiant un
bloc c'est un problème mathématique
extrêmement compliqué et donc chaque
noeud du réseau travaille en permanence
pour essayer de résoudre ce problème m
matic et trouver un identifiant pour sa
liste de transactions en attente et le
premier qui arrive peut proposer son
bloc et tout le monde se synchronise
dessus à ça ça me dit quelque chose
c'est le coup du problème de maths hyper
difficile à résoudre
sauf que moi j'aimerais comprendre
pourquoi c'est difficile à résoudre eh
ben on va voir ça on a vu que ce qui
permettait à la chaîne de blocs de se
construire de manière régulière c'est
que pour proposer un nouveau bloc il
fallait résoudre d'abord un problème
mathématique compliqué ce problème il
sert à trouver un nom au bloc un
identifiant pourtant trouvé un
identifiant ça a pas l'air très
compliqué comme problème alors pour vous
expliquer ça il faut d'abord que je vous
explique ce que c'est que le hachage une
fonction de hachage c'est une fonction
qui prend en entrée une chaîne de
caractères de n'importe quelle longueur
et qui donne en sortit une autre chaîne
de caractères qui est elle de longues
heures fixes par exemple ici on a 16
caractères est ce qu'on veut c'est que
le moindre changement dans la chaîne
d'entrée provoque un grand changement
dans la chaîne de sortie par exemple là
si je change un as en eau ou que
j'ajoute un point d'exclamation à la fin
de la phrase la chaîne de sortie est
complètement modifié une des
applications du hachage c'est de
vérifier qu'un téléchargement s'est bien
passé si vous téléchargez un gros
fichiers il ya toujours un risque qu'une
petite partie du fichier soit mal
transmise et que ça suffise à rendre
l'ensemble du fichier inutilisable une
solution c'est que celui qui met le
fichier en téléchargement le fait
d'abord passer dans une fonction de
hachage pour en sortir une chaîne de
caractères qui est en quelque sorte
l'empreinte digitale du fichier si le
fichier que vous avez reçu différents ne
serait ce que d'un beat du fichier
d'origine
le résultat de son match sera
complètement différent et vous pourrez
vous rendre compte qu'il ya un souci
c'est le principe de ce qu'on appelle la
somme de contrôle ou tchèques somme et
pour trouver un identifiant à chaque
nouveau bloc de la bloque chain on va
aussi utiliser le principe du hachage
pour ça on fabrique un fichier qui
contient toutes les transactions qu'on
veut valider ainsi que l'identifiant du
blog précédent et ont fait passer le
tout par une fonction de hachage on
obtient ainsi une suite de caractères
qu'on va utiliser comme identifiant et
ce qui fait que la chaîne est une chaîne
c'est que l'identifiant d'un bloc est
utilisé pour calculer l'identifiant du
bloc suivant l'intérêt de ce système
c'est de protéger la base de données
contre la moindre modification si vous
voulez changer une transaction même
juste rajouter 1 0 ça va complètement
changer le hachage et donc ça va changer
l'identifiant du bloc mais comme
l'identique
du bloc il est utilisé dans le hachage
du blog suivant il faut aussi changer
l'identifiant du bloc suivant et ainsi
de suite dans toute la chaîne donc
impossible d'aller changer une
transaction dans le passé sans avoir
calculé tous les identifiants de tous
les blocs qui sont arrivés depuis et je
vous rappelle un des blocs y en a 1
toutes les dix minutes
bon y'a pas à dire à mon avis ils ont
pensé à tout un salaire béton comme
protection cette box et ben j'en suis
pas si sûre d'après ce qui vient d'être
expliqué trouver un identifiant ne
repose que sur le hachage or une
fonction de hachage c'est pas si pire
que ça il ya même des tas de sites
internet qui peuvent le faire donc un
éventuel pirate pourrait tout à fait
rajouter ces blocs à toute vitesse dans
la blue jam non alors ce qui protège de
ça c'est le fait qu'on a ajouté des
conditions supplémentaires sur
l'identifiant qui fait que le trouvais
assez compliqué l'idée c'est que quand
on fabrique le fichier qu'on veut h et
on prend donc l'identifiant du blog
précédent
la liste des transactions mais on ajoute
aussi à la fin un nombre qu'on appelle
annonce et la présence de ce nom sera
évidemment modifier le résultat du
hachage et en fait on impose des
conditions sur le résultat qui font
qu'il faut essayer plein de noms ce
différend avant d'en trouver un qui
colle est le seul moyen d'y arriver
c'est la manière bourrine on essaye
plein de nonce à toute vitesse jusqu'à
en trouver un qui colle comme si on
essayait de trouver un digicode
d'immeubles en tapant plein de cadeaux
hasard et les conditions sont faites
pour qu'une solution soit trouvée en
moyenne toutes les 10 minutes dans le
réseau évidemment au fur à mesure que le
réseau grandit et que la puissance de
calcul des ordinateurs augmente on rend
les conditions de plus en plus difficile
pour rester sur cette moyenne de 10
minutes
donc si on résume chaque noeud du réseau
à sa liste de transactions en attente et
il travaille comme un bourrin pour faire
en sorte que cette liste de transactions
en attente devienne le prochain bloc
donc chacun essaye de trouver un
identifiant à sa liste de transactions
le premier qui arrive
eh ben il est l'élu et puis tout le
monde s'aligne sur lui et prend sa liste
de transactions comme étant le nouveau
bloc et on recommence ce qui est
intéressant avec ce système c'est qu'on
protège la bloque chain de la fraude en
demandant de manière un petit peu
artificielle au noeud du réseau de
résoudre un problème compliqué pour
avoir le droit de contribuer c'est ce
qu'on appelle la preuve de travail bah
oui pour contribuer il faut bosser
la conséquence de ça c'est que la
capacité à frauder elle devient liés à
la puissance de calcul dont on dispose
et pas au nombre de
du réseau qu'on possède parce que créer
plein des adresses ip pouvoir plein de
noeud du réseau c'est facile par contre
aligner un paquet de processeurs pour
aller plus vite que tous les autres
c'est une autre affaire voilà on est
presque au bout de la technologie de la
bloque chain iraient juste un problème à
résoudre
il existe une petite probabilité que
deux noeuds du réseau arrive à proposer
toutes les deux leurs blocs de manière
quasiment simultanés et puis il existe
aussi un tout petit risque que quelqu'un
arrive sur un des noeuds du réseau à
pirater un bloc ou deux s'il est
suffisamment puissant et avec un peu de
chance je suis pas sûr de comprendre la
imagine que david accepte de nous payer
10 bitcoin pour la lampe
on attend une dizaine de minutes et puis
la transaction apparaît dans un bloc a
priori ça veut dire que cette
transaction a bien été validé donc on
envoie la lampe à david sauf qu'à ce
moment-là il existe quand même encore
une chance que la transaction soit
piraté voire supprimés quoi comment
et oui et en cas de piratage du dernier
bloc ou bien si pas de chance deux du
réseau arrivent toutes les deux à
proposer leur bloc eh bien il se passe
un truc simple on se retrouve avec deux
chaînes de blocs différentes
et là la règle est simple tous les notes
du réseau doivent conserver les deux
chaînes
mais par contre on ne travaille que sur
la plus longue des deux ce qui fait que
très rapidement mais l'une des deux
chaînes va prendre le pas sur l'autre
donc avant de m'envoyer ta lampe le
mieux c'est quand même d'attendre
environ une heure un 5/6 bloc pour être
sûr que la transaction qui va te payer
elle fait partie d'un blog qui va bien
être dans la chaîne qu'on va conserver
on voit donc que dans le principe du
fonctionnement de la bloque chain donc
qui sécurise le bitcoin on est protégé
par le fait que chacun ne possède qu'une
faible puissance de calcul comparé au
total en fait si quelqu'un voulait
vraiment compromettre la blog shane il
faudrait qu'il possède plus de 50 % de
la puissance de calcul de tout le réseau
mais du coup on peut se demander
pourquoi est ce que tous les ordinateurs
du réseau accepterait de mettre leur
puissance de calcul au service de la
protection du bitcoin est bien il ya une
réponse simple pour ça c'est que on les
paye et on les paye en bitcoin il faut
savoir que quand un bloc et validé c'est
à dire qu'un noeud du réseau arrive à
résoudre le problème mathématique
compliqué il reçoit pour sa peine 25
bitcoin est au cours actuel du bitcoin
ça fait pas loin de dix mille euros
et c'est bitcoin ils viennent de nulle
part
ils sont créés artificiellement pour
l'occasion c'est d'ailleurs le seul
mécanisme de création de nouveaux
bitcoin et c'est pour ça que les
ordinateurs qui participent à la
sécurisation du réseau
on les appelle parfois des mineurs en
référence aux mineurs qui allaient
chercher de l'or pour augmenter la masse
monétaire alors dix mille euros pour
résoudre un problème mathématique
salaire quand même vachement intéressant
sauf que maintenant il faut mettre
tellement de puissance de calcul pour y
arriver le premier qu'il ya quasiment
aucune chance d'y arriver tout seul info
ce groupe et et puis le mécanisme est
telle que la récompense en bitcoin elle
va décroître au cours du temps et donc
au final la masse monétaire des bitcoins
on sait qu'elle va converger vers 21
millions de bitcoin pas plus on a ici
tous les avantages du système bitcoin on
a un système qui est centralisée sans
autorité de régulation avec un mécanisme
de création monétaire qui est connu
d'avancé transparent et des frais de
transactions qui sont réduits c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on entend surtout parler
du bitcoin pour des transactions
illicites ou bien pour des logiciels
malveillants qui vous crypte votre
ordinateur et vous demandent des rançons
en échange
enfin quand même avant de vous lancer
dans le grand banditisme avec le bitcoin
garder en tête que l'anonymat il est que
théorique
c'est vrai que votre nom n'apparaît pas
explicitement dans les transactions et
si vous êtes le seul à avoir votre clé
privée
en principe vous êtes le seul à savoir
que c'est vous qui avez fait la
transaction
sauf qu'il a déjà été montré sur des
exemples qu'on pouvait assez facilement
des anonymisées des données en se basant
sur des motifs récurrents et oubliés par
un tout ce qui est inscrit dans la
bloque chain est quelque chose qui est
éternel
impossible à modifier donc pensez-y
avant d'aller acheter la drogue
d'ailleurs au delà du bitcoin on peut
penser à tout un tas d'autres
d'applications pour la blocs shane
notamment dans des situations où on
souhaite afficher des informations
publiquement mais de manière un
falsifiable comme par exemple pour faire
du vote en ligne
du notariat aujourd'hui il est
évidemment difficile de prédire l'avenir
du bitcoin ou bien les applications de
la blog shane
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à mon avis
on risque d'en entendre encore beaucoup
parler dans les prochaines années
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo merci à
gilles qui m'a aidé et n'hésitez pas à
aller voir sa vidéo ne donne pas mal de
détails dont j'ai parlé dans cette vidéo
merci beaucoup et nota bene qui m'a
laissé gagner au bras de fer si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'oubliez pas de
la partager notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez suivre les actus de
la chaîne sur facebook twitter vous
pouvez me soutenir sur tipi vous pouvez
aller lire le billet qui accompagne
cette vidéo sur mon blog sur ce étonnant
pour plus d'information pour plus
technique et vous pouvez aussi aller
jeter un oeil à mon livre que j'ai sorti
de chez flammarion merci à bientôt